an do
hyun
year
olga na williams elexander
in london &
papas vladimir putin oni and price for
both ends
highlighted b.f.  Putin has changed a lot over the
past twenty-odd years
because he did not just lead the country,
he led the country under conditions of
absolutely autocratic rule, and
if earlier he was a person who
listens carefully and is cautious,
now it has changed, he is confident of his
infallibility and he
is capable of various kinds, including  the
steps of
paradise and he is
round lake of agafya
are not prudent, but shame and so on an inch and
edge
you should understand that for Putin the
events in Ukraine
when the Maidan happened there and Viktor Yanukovych was demolished,
whom Putin considered
his vassals, this was very
traumatic for him  experience, he believed that
this is what the Americans did and this is the
first step before attacking him
personally on his authorities in Russia, and
for Putin it was and remains
fundamentally important that Russia
perceive Ukraine
as a country affected by the
Maidan due to the demolition of authoritarian
rule
due to the fact that it was  removed you from
Putin, he is very welcome  It is important that Russia
does not perceive this as a failure and he
does everything for
this.  the law does not protect
you if you are not a legitimately elected
leader if in order to
get elected you had to violate the
constitution
rig elections and so on you
understand that you are very dependent on the
perception of you by your environment if
your environment is afraid of you and you
are beneficial to them then you are alive if your  the environment
considers you weak, then you
most likely will stop living, which is why it
is fundamentally important for Putin
not to look weak
from the
boarding school is protected,
pass today, of course, the
opposition
in Russia is reduced to a
minimum level,
this is done through arrests, this is done
through
pressure on relatives, but this also
means
that  op  the positional mood has gone deeper
and
Putin today doesn’t really know
how society is what they relate to, this is
one of the reasons why he
is afraid to actually start a war in
Ukraine because he is not sure that
Russian society will not only
support it, but I think that of course
Russian society is not support he is
not sure how strong the backlash will be
and
it can be very strong we must
understand that russia ukraine
are actually very close strange
not only geographically 30 million
russian families are actually either
mixed or have relatives in
ukraine or  left Ukraine and
this is for Putin that very serious challenge
that he is afraid to step over, but on the
other hand, he
understands that he himself has raised the stakes so
high that it’s just to say that we
’re playing back, it’s for him to
show himself weak, and this, as I
said, is big
there is a danger
he
gave monica
delayed your assets
bad
further and here are the spots of clicks  olga you
pop-up ads in london it's about sex i'm here
people call mana date
x2 and run
you under forgive he m n people around in
buy essences son o
interacting access miracle money in london
in my opinion the pressure on
property and
assets of Putin's entourage have  two
meanings
1 meaning this
is the situation when Putin's entourage
uses this money to
illegally influence the British
political system and this happens
directly indirectly through
law firms through lobbying
industrialists through direct
influence on politicians and so on
this is the most dangerous story, it
really needs to be seriously fought
second  the story is more of an ethical plan,
are the British ready to put up with
dirty money from Ukraine, my money on their
territory, but this is the choice of the British
society,
as for the impact on
Putin’s decision, it’s clear that for him the
assets of his entourage that are
on enemy territory,
which for him is Britain, is
rather with  a vision of some kind of
betrayal, unless these assets are
used to influence the
British political system,
so to speak, so yes, it has some impacts,
but no, this impact is not
serious, the most
serious impact, of course,
is the
arming and
training of the Ukrainian army, which as a
result
demonstrates to Putin that
there is no  aggression will not be a cakewalk